Selecciona todas las relaciones descritas
por la siguiente ecuación,
"y" es igual a 7/8 de "x"
Y me dan opción, A, B, C y D.
Vamos a analizarlas caso por caso.
Un ramo de 8 rosas cuesta 7 pesos en "Flores de Flora",
supongo que ésta es una florería extremadamente barata, un ramo con 12 rosas cuesta 11 pesos.
La ecuación describe la relación entre el
número de rosas "x"
y su precio en "Flores de Flora" "y".
Bien, para verificar esto vamos a hacer una
pequeña tabla en la que voy a comparar el
número de rosas "x" contra el precio que
tienen en "Flores de Flora", "y",
contra el valor de la ecuación, "y" es igual a 7/8
de "x", entonces aquí voy a poner 7/8 de "x".
Bien, entonces, ¿cuánto vale esto?
Pues veamos.
Si yo compró 7... perdón, 8 rosas... si
yo compro 8 rosas en "Flores de Flora",
me cuesta 7 pesos,
un ramo con 8 rosas, cuesta 7 pesos.
¿Pero cuánto vale 7/8 de "x"?
Pues 7/8 de "x", sería 7/8 de 8, los 8 se
cancelan y me queda 7,
por lo tanto al menos para este caso si es cierto que "y"es igual a 7/8 de "x".
¿Pero qué pasa si yo compro 12 rosas?
Si yo compro 12 rosas, entonces debería pagar
11 pesos en "Flores de Flora",
¿pero cuánto vale 7/8 de 12?...
7/8 de 12, pues esto es lo mismo que
7 por 3 y divido todo entre 4, 7 por 3 entre 2...
déjenme me hago tantito hacia acá...
7 por 3 entre 2, ¿qué cuánto es 7 por 3?
es 21 entre 2, sería 10.5...
10.5 no es lo mismo que 11 por lo tanto estas
dos cosas son distintas,
de modo que la opción A no puede ser correcta puesto que "y" no siempre es igual a 7/8 de "x".
¿Que hay de la opción B?
Hay un descuento del 12.5% en cada artículo
de la tienda "José el Loco".
La ecuación describe la relación entre el
precio de un artículo antes del descuento
"x" y su precio tras aplicar el descuento "y".
Bien, entonces tenemos este porcentaje,
tenemos un descuento del 12.5%.
Ahora el 12.5% de algún artículo...
12.5%... lo puedo escribir en términos de
una fracción como 12.5 entre 100,
12.5 de cada 100, pero esto es lo mismo que... si
multiplico todo por 10, 125 entre 1000...
125 entre 1000.
¿Pero cuánto es 125 entre 1000?
Pues todo es divisible entre 125, por lo tanto
si divido el numerador y el denominador
por 125, obtengo 1/8, por lo tanto a cada artículo
le voy a rebajar una octava parte de su precio.
De modo que al artículo, si tiene un precio
original "x", que es lo que estoy diciendo aquí,
antes del descuento tiene un precio "x"
entonces después del descuento va a tener un precio de "x" menos el descuento aplicado a "x".
Pero el descuento es de 1/8 el precio, por
lo tanto sería "x" menos 1/8 de "x"
y esto simplemente sería 7/8 de "x", pero lo que
estoy haciendo aquí es aplicar el descuento
por lo tanto tengo que "y" que es el precio
después del descuento es igual a 7/8 de "x".
De modo que B sí es correcta.
B sí es correcta.
Muy bien.
Vamos con C, la entrada a un campo de gotcha
cuesta 7 pesos e incluye 8 municiones,
cada munición adicional cuesta 1 peso.
La ecuación describe la relación entre el
número de municiones "x" y el precio pagado "y".
Bueno el gotcha es este juego, en el que vas
a un campo y le disparas bolas de pintura a tus amigos.
Entonces, lo que me están diciendo
es que la entrada al campo
para poder jugar cuesta 7 pesos, incluye 8 municiones.
De nuevo, vamos a hacer una tablita por aquí,
así como le hicimos para la opción A.
Vamos a poner el número de municiones "x",
el precio pagado "y"
y de nuevo vamos a poner 7/8 de "x" que es el valor contra el que queremos comparar a "y".
Vamos a ver.
Si hago mi tablita así, entonces tengo que
si tengo 8 municiones entonces pagué 7 pesos
para entrar al campo y de nuevo puedo verificar
que 7/8 de "x" en este caso,
es lo mismo que 7/8 por 8, los 8 se cancelan y me queda 7, por lo tanto "y" si es 7/8 de "x" para este caso.
Ahora, cada munición adicional cuesta 1 peso,
entonces si yo tuviera 9 municiones o... sí,
vamos a hacer 9 municiones... 9 municiones,
entonces yo debería de haber pagado 8 pesos.
De modo que es cierto que 8 es 7/8 por 9,
pues veamos.
7/8 por "x", "x" ahorita vale 9... entonces
por 9... ¿y esto cuánto va a ser?
Pues 7 por 9 es 63 entre 8, 8 por 8 es 64,
por lo tanto esto es tantito menos que 8,
esto es menor que 8.
Pero entonces este número "y" y este número
de aquí, no pueden ser iguales, de modo que
esta relación tampoco es cierta.
Vamos a tacharla.
Tampoco es cierta la D... perdón, la C.
Finalmente, la ecuación corresponde a la
gráfica a continuación
y me dan esta gráfica de aquí.
Esta gráfica.
Pues vamos a ver.
Cuando "x" vale 0, la relación... recuerden
que estoy tratando de pensar en la relación
"y" igual a 7/8 de "x"... 7/8 de "x"...
entonces si "x" vale 0, "y"también vale 0,
por lo tanto el punto 0, 0 debería estar
en la gráfica y sí lo está.
Y cuando "x" vale 8... cuando "x" vale 8,
entonces tengo que "y" es igual a
7/8 por 8, los 8 se cancelan y me queda 7, por lo
tanto, cuando "x" vale 8, "y" debe valer 7.
y es este punto de aquí que sí está sobre
7, por lo tanto estos dos puntos están en la gráfica
y ésta gráfica sí describe
la relación proporcional que nos dan.
Por lo tanto, las opciones que yo diría son
correctas, son la opción B y la opción D.